are you ready John are you ready Scott
don't fight with the light sabers gold
use your aggressive feelings boy
knocks out the little faster keeping Oh
one of you will be my new apprentice I
kind of go through it with soccer thing
over there
over there yes yes don't tell you know
everyone yes nicely done
ha ha ha Killian strike him down with
all your hate and your journey to the
dark side will become free you know we
got episode I'm the Empire critic and
this is pop quiz hotshot Star Wars
edition I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
ever since I was a child I always want
to play games quoting movies and TV with
my friends the only problem was I had no
friends well now that I have power I can
take my friends by force with the help
of my new pal general anaesthetic
I can kidnap all the friends I want and
force them to answer questions they
might say by the Bell style cent there
will be laughs trivia those disturbing
cartoons that give you night terrors but
most of all there will be fun the
laughter and joy will last however long
I want
heads up America or this is pop quiz
hotshot
[Music]
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot special
edition I'm gonna be totally cg in a
minute
now you know what I want change it the
other way now I won't be CG it's just
every five seconds I have like a new
idea you know what next time we'll go
back to physical challenge I'll make the
other guy win first okay that's how
we'll do it
all right Scott it says here that you
are a 2d animator voice actor and even
have a website called Scott MacArthur
ate at deviantART Dhaka dot
deviantart.com
yes I am and I swore if I make it out of
here alive I am open for our commissions
I think has some commissions he might be
interested in commissions of putting
bullets in your body that jerk with no
weapons John it says here that you have
something I can very much relate to a
failed YouTube channel not to make
people collect about that John why are
you so proud about that it was fun while
it lasted well if it was more people
would watch it but what was it about
John it was it's called the John Grant
show actually it's weird like variety
goofy crap going on yeah we would have
no idea about any of that around yeah
all right in our special edition Star
Wars edition we are going to ask nothing
but Star Wars questions but first you
need to know the rules but here are the
rules
each contestant is asked a series of
questions involving the sounds of quotes
if the contestant does not know the
answer but can make the Nostalgia Critic
laugh ten points are still given but
look out for the spasms the first one to
hit their buzzer when they appear ends
the round while the other has to pay the
penalty through round two where the
quotes get even harder the winner with
the most points face off against the
nostalgia critic and a one-on-one match
if the contestant wins they walk out
with a cash prize and also their lives
if they lose the cash prize will be
added to the next contestants winning
good Scott
John are you ready all right John what
character in the special edition of a
new hope said sir
Luke is the best bush pilot in the
outer-rim territories Thanks
yes Wow even I'm amazed at that I'm
dressed like this believe me watch the
special edition start in the original
version of Return of the Jedi what was
the title of the Ewok celebratory song
it's so easy to remember come on
everybody speech Ewok it's like Spanish
yum yum PJ yum yum I would have just
accepted the under bond is made on I
think contestant for this was John in
the Empire Strikes Back
how many Imperial officers does Darth
Vader cook two three or four three row
two
come on you think he's a psycho or
something a calling to Threepio I'd like
to point out they're three Theo is
actually spelled out yay I'm trusting
the person who spelled Threepio wrong to
ask these questions ever mind I'll choke
him later
according to Threepio the letters and
the numbers what nests in the pit of the
cocoon the Sarlacc pit yes good
impression I'd love to c-3po with a
watchman to it that just it said be a
magnet probably but still John finish
this Obi one line you can't win Darth if
you strike me down I shall become more
powerful nigga possibly imagine yes yeah
so powerful who and kind of see-through
in blue gotcha
I want everything I want ever Scott in
the Phantom Menace oh you're in trouble
what character said Tatooine is sparsely
populated if the homing trace is correct
I will find them quickly master
[Music]
we're trying to levitate me there for a
second assignment though you're trying
to use the boys mmm you know in wookie
that actually translates out to Darfur
Mall but I want in English so it doesn't
Captain John when mop talk in that's a
good mother
no get name you bought ask for the
location of the secret rebel base what
planet does lay a name Dan to him
yes not between Empire Strikes Back and
Return of the Jedi Luke's lightsaber
color changes from what to what from
blue to green yes John in a new hope
what creatures did Luke used to bullseye
in his feet huh womp rats yes say what
ever seen a want rat you know what they
called Aladdin Scott what took you in
here but you got it you got it
what does the 8080 in 8080 Walker stand
for abnormal technology closer
all-terrain Ian armored transport so
when I say close I meant not even
remotely clear so John what does the TI
e in Thai fighter stand for twin iron
engine wow I mean wow you just live on
Wikipedia don't you you probably run it
Scott in a new hope Princess Leia was
both a princess and what a diplomat for
all the world
you know I'm gonna give that to you it's
actually senator or ambassador but
princess is doing good you know it's
always like oh I just spin around and
sync the flowers it's never know you can
be a diplomat so good for you good for
you well better roles for women with
cinnamon bun hair John in the special
edition of a new hope Han called Java a
wonderful what human being
yes how does that make sense
just go from one special edition to
Whelan's horrible to another special
edition where you love to ass just see
them to doom back-to-back if you can
find it because he find got rid of all
the other special editions a stupid
special international Scot which admiral
for the Empire was the only one to
survive to Return of the Jedi and repeat
yes which one of my new apprentices cuz
it John you seem to have avoided the
spazzy attack Scott that means that you
have to face the penalty of my choosing
and I say that such a good Yoda
impression I'm just gonna have you be
Yoda throughout the rest of the game
wow that goes on we shall witness the
spicy cartoon hey Elizabeth
you wanna play Star Wars today oh but
come on a Darth Vader I have the floors
I can even break your neck Wow even a
galaxy far far away gets real and
oh I had a weird lightsaber battle with
you and one of the movies didn't I you
know why do you tell me the cane if you
can fling around with the lightsaber and
stuff you're just a great insurance
people are gonna show up screw with
people I like - good answer I like you
we are now going into round 2 and this
round we are starting with John in the
Empire Strikes Back
when Leia calls hard a scruffy-looking
nerf-herder
what his hands were pluck who's
scruffy-looking yes Scott according to
Han Solo the Millennium Falcon made the
Kessel run in less than what 12 parsecs
yes good good John true or false the
character mon mothma appeared in all
three of the original Star Wars films
boss Great Scott
when Luke tells the Emperor his
overconfidence is his weakness what is
his reply your friends and girlfriends
is your indeed it is it is
job what major design advantage does
r2d2 have in Revenge of the Sith that is
conspicuously missing in Episode four
and six things yeah yeah what was that
was it
there's like a million situations he
could have gone out oh that's suddenly
oh I have rocket packs now next to c-3po
I have a machine gun pop out of his fist
or something it's so weird scotch
name the four alphabetical rebel fighter
wings that appear in episodes four
through six you could just shout random
letters you'll probably be right though
is a B X Y Y because we like John
outside of Luke Skywalker which rogue
squadron pilot was the only one to make
it through all three of the original
Star Wars movies what answer is Wow
even though his last name your Magic Man
Scott what is the name of the Wookiee
home planet where Yoda had such good
relations Kirk yes I don't know what
good relations he had with them and
there'd be a little Yoda wookie running
around but the less I know about the
better what happens on kiss your kiss
you
cool cool
cuz I did a lot of stuff on kitchen okay
John in Return of the Jedi Mon Mothma
says many of what mysterious race died
to give them the death star information
the Bothans okay oh you know what if
often is I mean do they ever show them
do they have a story to them a sitcom
and all do you don't they look like no
okay this mysterious thing I just want
to make sure you were still human
because you seem to know everything
about this movie it's pretty scary Scott
in a new hope Luke claims Ben Kenobi
lives out beyond where terms of
chattering close the dune see John
to or false Lando Calrissian never said
I have a bad feeling about this true
correct
when Leia says I should have expected
you holding Vader's leash who is she
referring to governor Tarkin yes
Jon what 50 characters said in the
prequels Republic credits Republic
credits are no good out here I need
something more real what oh yes
you know whatto what how do you remember
these names it's like he just opened up
a dictionary and said Oh take half of
that and half of this and it's her own
five more letters he's a good friend of
mine really yeah she nice he doesn't
accept Robo republic rights he's
actually kind of a dick oh really weird
Scott
in Return of the Jedi who said yes I
said closer move as close as you can and
engage those stardestroyers at
point-blank range Lando and that means
we're at the end of the level we have
Scott at 90 John at a hundred and fifty
damn man you are incredible which sadly
means Scott's dead you are grass is your
ass time for you to go a lightsaber
battle which I may or may not have won
is now won by me now so that is do it
yes indeed goodbye goodbye you are but
good for me it is so now you wait how's
he doing that well my god he really did
become a problem I possibly imagine sure
you're not gonna be in the final level
you John you are in the final level I'm
not gonna lie I'm very afraid to go up
against you so we will see how this goes
force is really freakin strong with you
man go outside your room we will be back
right after you kids in a pop quiz hot
shot and live in the Chicagoland area
send a video via YouTube stating your
name a and why you think it would be a
good contestant
[Music]
welcome back to pop quiz hotshot charm
congratulations
you will be battling against the Emperor
in our final round I'll be reading seven
questions whoever answers the most
correctly well will this your realm
idiot glory encounter Oh way that
refused to believe midi-chlorians exists
this doesn't either how about instead we
give you $150 in cash and of course your
life
excellent all right I'll be reading a
group of quotes from c-3po human-cyborg
relations
you'll have to identify which movie it's
from critic are you ready let's do it
Jon are you ready you will not win this
excellent let's begin John now don't you
forget this where I should stick my neck
out for you as far beyond my capacity I
new hope correct critic I can assure you
they will never get me onto one of those
dreadful starships correct John this is
such a drag correct critic what could
possibly have come over master Luke this
is something I did he never expressed
any unhappiness with my work return the
Jedi correct John I really don't see how
this is going to help surrender is a
perfectly acceptable alternative in
extreme circumstances the Empire Strikes
Back correct critic I feel so helpless
new home incorrect John did you hear
that they shut down the main reactor
will be destroyed for sure this is
madness
Empire incorrect critic stormtroopers
here for in danger I must tell the
others Oh No I've been shot at very
straight back correct John oh my what
have you done I'm backwards
correct critic what is all this a battle
there must be some mistake
I am programmed for etiquette not
destruction Revenge of the Sith
incorrect
John wonderful we are now part of the
tribe I returned the day correct critic
you know I think I'm getting the hang of
this flying business attack of the
clones incorrect
John r2d2 you know better than to trust
a strange computer new hope incorrect
and finally critic he made a fair move
giving up
can't help you a new hope correct and
the winner is
[Applause]
are you sure your thoughts on this are
quite clear all right all right you win
the prize well done well done go out
there meet some women after you're
married aren't you damn it I can't make
that insult well the fourth is not as
strong with me as I thought are we edit
in the special edition until then I will
see you next time on pop quiz you know
you remember in return to Jedi we're
likely zapped to you and you're all like
burning on the ground and stuff and I
wanted your son to come you and then he
wouldn't so I'm like hey come back to my
side you know it's all cool why didn't I
expect you to throw me a big diamond
yeah yeah yeah kind of weird even
weirder that Scotch is coming back as a
blue goes right so it was pretty dang
cool yeah yeah that was really uh
probably a hot affect to do too but
nevertheless I think he did have a
website though didn't he yeah yeah like
maybe if you know with the fourth power
I will put in the credits there it is
yes yeah so you can go check that out
while I still try to figure out all the
weird film holes in these movies even
the originals like the special editions
fix them all up though didn't raise any
more questions whatsoever right boys
indeed yeah no one's gonna suck I said
it I'm like it's gonna be awesome
[Music]
you